bullet cat podcast man you already know
Blanco Six coming April 7th
Milly's is in the building
dropping off an acapella clip one time
let's get right to it baby tint the
windows on the Range Rover it's hard
dealing with my pain sober but I'm
balling to the games over ice around my
body I'm surrounded by the flame
throwers kill you on camera for you see
me hearing this chain over I Did It For
My City even though half of these
goofies hating my music playing in the
same towns I was moving waiting I used
to put it on a scale like a boxer when
they do the weigh-ins cut all my old
[__] off I'm having new relations
throughout the nation brought the
dumpers with us Gotta Buy the bouncer
ain't no thumping with us keep it honest
with yourself you never seen no [__]
like this in your life a hundred
thousand worth of ice I'm in the
trenches tonight and they respect it
cause it's genuine see it in my eyes I
don't really roll them windows down or
hop down and let it fly lettuce music
ship it I throw it all away for my pride
I talk to life is more than anyone free
all of my gods on God
Milly's man Blanco six April 7th go see
this man yeah boom hey I know you just
watched a new freestyle guess what we're
dropping them every week sometimes more
than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week